Could Marvel be planning even more shocking
deaths in their "Spider-Man" franchise?
Keep watching to find out why they might be!
Cap had such a beautiful ending in "Avengers:
Endgame" with Peggy Carter, and if that was
tarnished in any way, fans might take to the
streets.
Leading up to "Avengers: Endgame," fans long
suspected that either Tony or Steve would
die, with many assuming there wasn't a world
where both would meet their end.
All across social media, MCU stans guessed
who would perish out of the two, and it seemed
to be split right down the middle.
In a popular Reddit thread, MCU fans were
forced to choose between the two men, but
there was no consensus among the dozens of
users who participated.
It's simple; no one wanted either man to die,
but for the story's sake, one had to.
With Tony's death set in stone in the Sacred
Timeline, losing Steve as well in the future
would just be too much — and bringing him
back only to kill him off would be even worse.
Just ask "Star Wars" fans!
“RAHHHHH!”
"NO!"
One thing is absolutely certain: if they kill
Thor, we riot!
With both Natasha and Tony six feet under,
and Steve off living in some other timeline,
the only remaining original Avengers we have
left are Thor, Hawkeye, and the Hulk.
Of those, Thor is easily the most popular,
so if he were to die, it would be nothing
but a big bummer.
It would have to be someone or something serious
to take him out, of course.
But while that might make for a great scene,
we'd really rather avoid it altogether.
There's no telling what fate awaits him in
"Thor: Love and Thunder," but we do know that
Hemsworth wants to play the character forever,
telling This Morning in 2019,
"I'd play this character for as long as anyone
let me, you know.
As I've said, I've loved it so much."
If we were to list some of the most badass
people in all of the MCU, you better believe
Okoye is going to be near the top of that
list.
With no superpowers, the Wakandan has proven
she's a force to be reckoned with, knocking
out her fair share of Outriders in both the
Battle of Wakanda and the Battle of Earth.
She is fiercely loyal to her home country,
even putting it above her love for her partner
in "Black Panther."
Okoye's dedication to her people and whatever
mission is at hand makes her easy to root
for, no matter what film she's in.
We know she'll be appearing in "Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever" and the untitled Wakanda
Disney+ series, and we hope she makes it out
of the latter alive.
We hope T'Challa's family and closest allies
make it through each and every impending battle
so they can continue to honor his legacy.
This one should go without saying, but the
death of Happy Hogan would absolutely crush
fans of the MCU.
He has been in the universe since day one,
appearing in six films as one of Tony Stark's
best friends, and as a mentor to Peter Parker.
Happy just has that good guy quality about
him, and watching him almost die in "Iron
Man 3" had us wanting revenge on Aldrich Killian
ourselves.
It turns out Happy was supposed to die in
the film, according to storyboards from the
first script.
We're not sure why the change was made, opting
to have Happy survive the explosion, but we're
sure glad they decided to go with a more positive
outcome.
How the character is changed by the events
of "Spider-Man: No Way Home" remains to be
seen, but here's hoping he finally gets a
true Happy ending.
Rocket might be a little bit of a jerk most
of the time, but we know it's because he's
suffered from quite a difficult life.
He definitely has strong feelings when it
comes to those he loves, primarily for Groot
as we saw him weep when his friend first died
in "Guardians of the Galaxy."
Um, and then again when Groot died the second
time in "Avengers: Infinity War."
If Rocket were to die in an upcoming project,
we suspect audiences wouldn't take it very
well.
To be fair, whenever an animal dies in a movie,
it always seems to have a more significant
impact on the viewer than when a human dies.
But we don't need any "Old Yeller" moments
in the MCU.
Seeing a poor little raccoon — albeit a
wisecracking, mutated one — die on the big
screen would be truly devastating.
Just take Peter Quill instead, we're begging
you!
Florence Pugh took the MCU by storm after
debuting as Yelena Belova in "Black Widow."
Serving as the sister of Natasha Romanoff,
the former assassin helped fight back against
the baddies to take down the Red Room, ultimately
coming out victorious.
The film wasn't without its flaws, but it
was widely accepted that one of the best things
about "Black Widow" was Yelena, thanks to
Pugh's stellar portrayal.
From the way she poked fun at her sister's
superhero landing to her convincing breakdown
at the family reunion, Yelena is one of the
more relatable MCU characters out there, and
fans only grew to love her hore thanks to
her surprise appearance in the Disney+ series
"Hawkeye," which tied everything together.
"You got so much time with her."
"Yes, I did."
Someone needs to carry on Natasha's legacy,
and there is no one better to do it than her.
If Marvel kills off Yelena somewhere down
the line, it's going to be one hell of a hit
to the MCU fandom.
Spider-Man has always been one of the most
widely loved superheroes, and the massive
success of the Sam Raimi -directed trilogy
in the early-mid '00s is definitely proof
of how much fans always wanted to see the
web-slinger on the big screen.
Star Tom Holland does a stellar job of portraying
the MCU's Spidey.
He brings an innocence to the character in
ways not captured by Tobey Maguire or Andrew
Garfield, and his naive nature fits the teenage
hero to a tee.
Technically, yes, we did see Peter die in
the finale of "Avengers: Infinity War," and
it was the biggest gut punch of them all.
Despite Holland being in the MCU a shorter
amount of time compared to other fan-favorites,
his "Infinity War" death proved how much audiences
have accepted his version of Spider-Man.
Putting the permanent kibosh on Tom Holland's
Peter would leave the MCU fandom reeling for sure.
Groot made his MCU debut in "Guardians of
the Galaxy," and was immediately loved by
all, despite only speaking four different
words in the entire film — five if you count
his name.
Groot is fiercely loyal, especially to Rocket,
and he has a ride-or-die nature that isn't
evident in all Marvel film characters.
This was evident in his ultimate sacrifice
at the end of the movie, where he creates
a cradle out of his body to save the rest
of the Guardians from an otherwise deadly
crash.
Viewers fell for the talking tree in just
two hours, and his death in the film was shocking.
We had just been introduced to this new superhero
team, and losing one of the members right
off the bat was a bold writing choice.
Luckily, we didn't have to wallow in our grief
for too long as it was revealed in the movie's
finale that a part of his shattered body was
planted, and a new Groot was born.
While teenage Groot tends to be annoyingly
angsty, we know that inside he's pure of heart.
Watching Groot suffer a permanent death would
be pretty difficult, and watching other Guardians
go before bidding farewell to the beloved
tree might be easier.
Like, say, Peter Quill!
Now that would be a better plan.
"I like your plan, except, it sucks.
So let me do the plan, and that way, it might
be really good."
With two solo films and two team-ups under
his belt, Scott Lang has become a staple in
the MCU.
Serving as one of the sillier characters in
the film universe, Scott instantly got the
fandom behind him, and he's become one of
the MCU's leading stars with characters like
Tony Stark, Steve Rogers, and Natasha Romanoff
out of the game.
If Scott were to die in the upcoming "Ant-Man
and the Wasp: Quantumania" or another team-up
film, the MCU fandom would riot — on their
computers.
It's not so much that killing off Ant-Man
would devastate moviegoers, as much as saying
goodbye to star Paul Rudd would.
His comedy never feels forced, and there is
so much more to explore with the character.
No more Scott means no more Rudd in Marvel
projects, and that's not something we're prepared
to handle just yet.
Wanda Maximoff has one of the most complex
story arcs in all of the MCU.
As a matter of fact, it doesn't seem like
her arc is even close to being finished at
this point as she has only recently become
the Scarlet Witch after the events of "WandaVision."
While it looks like she might be on the path
to darkness, watching Wanda die would be pretty
painful.
We know the true, good-natured Wanda is still
in there somewhere — we're just hoping light
triumphs over evil in her next few appearances.
That's all.
Wanda has had way too much happen to her in
her life, from the death of her parents, to
the death of her brother Pietro, to the many
deaths of Vision, to the complete breakdown
of her not-so-happily-ever-after in Westview
— the woman needs a break.
If anyone deserves a happy ending, it's Wanda,
and that certainly isn't going to happen with
her death.
"That doesn't seem fair!"
There are awesome MCU characters, and then
there are protect-at-all-costs characters,
and one of those is Mr. Jimmy Woo.
First debuting in "Ant-Man and the Wasp,"
Jimmy was a funny, quirky FBI agent assigned
as Scott Lang's parole officer.
There is something so endearing about Jimmy,
which was further amplified when he showed
up in Westview for "WandaVision."
He fights for the side of good and rebels
against leadership when he knows something
is afoot.
The allure of Jimmy Woo is similar to that
of his frenemy Scott Lang, as both characters
are played by actors loved by the public.
If anyone played Jimmy other than Randall
Park, fans across the globe might have been
less likely to fall in love with the agent.
Throughout the airing of "WandaVision," viewers
campaigned across social media to get Jimmy
his own spinoff series, according to The Direct.
Some Redditors even dubbed him the best new
Marvel character, so if he dies off in a future
phase, we can expect some serious backlash
from fans.
One of the best moves ever made in the MCU's
casting history was the switch from Terrence
Howard to Don Cheadle for the part of Colonel
James Rhodes.
Sometimes those kinds of actor replacements
can ruin the movie, but that wasn't the case
at all here.
Rhodes is another of Tony Stark's closest
friends and confidants who always has his
back.
He's also instrumental in the fight against
Thanos and one of the few who participates
in the Time Heist.
We've been through so much with Rhodes that
seeing him go down would be difficult to watch.
Case in point, it looked like Rhodes met his
end in "Captain America: Civil War" after
Vision accidentally knocked him out of the
sky.
When he hit the ground, audiences across the
world gasped.
It was a moment when many MCU fans realized
they cared a hell of a lot more about the
character than they thought they did.
It would be tough to watch that kind of moment
again with Rhodes, as we need as many people
as we can to carry on the memory of Iron Man.
With Cheadle set to return in the upcoming
Disney+ series "Armor Wars," we hope nothing
but good things are on the horizon for War
Machine.
We've seen a love interest of Spider-Man die
on the big screen before, and it's nothing
we're interested in going through again.
The death of Gwen Stacy in "The Amazing Spider-Man
2" was a total shock (except to anyone who
has ever read the comics, of course), and
if that type of twist was delivered twice
to Spider-Man fans, it would be way out of
bounds.
Zendaya does an incredible job portraying
MJ in the MCU's "Spider-Man" films, and following
the events of "Spider-Man: Far From Home,"
it would be even more devastating to lose her.
Sometimes close friends and love interests
are killed off in films to give the protagonist
the push they need to defeat the big bad,
but we're hoping that's not a route the MCU
takes with MJ.
With a talent like Zendaya on your roster,
it's best to keep her around as long as possible.
It took all of one episode for "Loki" viewers
to fall in love with Mobius M. Mobius, the
Time Variance Authority agent played by the
charming Owen Wilson.
The actor had undeniable chemistry with Loki
himself, Tom Hiddleston, and every scene involving
the duo was pure magic.
Fans absolutely lost their minds when Mobius
seemingly died in Episode 4 of the series
after being pruned by Judge Renslayer.
We had only known him for a few episodes,
but the determined yet kind TVA agent became
a favorite in no time.
Thankfully, we found out in Episode 5 that
one doesn't die when they're pruned but instead
transported to The Void at the End of Time.
It's usually a death sentence, but Mobius
was able to get out, in addition to surviving
all the events of "Loki," which suggests we
will see Wilson back in action.
If we lose Mobius in a future MCU project,
fans will not go quietly.
For weeks, the fandom took to social media
to express their love for the mustache-rocking
agent, with many a thread on Reddit dedicated
to the hopes of seeing Mobius on a jet ski
in the future.
If he does die — which he better not — we
just hope he has one hell of a ride on a Sea-Doo
before biting the bullet.
Wong is a force to be reckoned with in the
MCU, and we're not quite sure the sorcerer's
full potential has been revealed just yet.
When he first debuted in "Doctor Strange,"
it seemed like Wong would primarily serve
as a sidekick to Stephen Strange, but the
last several years have proven he's his own
man.
Wong has shown up in five different MCU flicks
and also has a big role in "Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness."
If Wong is killed off, it's going to send
some serious waves through fandom.
The character is undoubtedly a fan favorite
thanks to his dedication to his craft and
perfectly timed one-liners.
"It's funny!"
Wong feels like a security blanket, always
there to protect you and make you feel warm
and fuzzy.
Losing Wong wouldn't just be a blow to the
fans, but the MCU as a whole — especially
Doctor Strange.
Without Wong to keep the Sorcerer Supreme
in line, the ramifications of losing him could
be catastrophic to the entire MCU.
Shuri just might be the most intelligent character
in the MCU right now.
Rocket might give her a run for her money,
but with Tony Stark in the ground and the
Hulk constantly switching between forms, the
Wakandan is one of the brightest minds on
the planet.
While it's still up in the air what role she
will move into in "Black Panther: Wakanda
Forever," Shuri is likely to play a more significant
role in the MCU as a whole.
The loss of Shuri isn't something audiences
would handle very well, especially since she
is the only child of King T'Chaka left.
And as with Okoye, it would be pretty difficult
to see the loss of another major Wakandan
character.
Shuri has so much to offer the world and her
superhero friends that her loss would be devastating
on so many levels.
Justifying her death would be a difficult
task for writers, and we're hoping she sticks
around for quite some time.
Talk about an MCU character who has been through
the wringer.
Bucky Barnes — aka the Winter Soldier — has
appeared in five films and one Disney+ series,
serving as the loyal best friend of Steve
Rogers.
Despite his hardened exterior, Bucky has long
been a fan-favorite in the MCU who has one
of the most tragic character arcs in the Infinity
Saga.
He has persevered despite being brainwashed
by the enemy, and comes full circle and repents
for his past transgressions in "The Falcon
and the Winter Soldier."
Some fans on Reddit were bummed out that he
didn't take on the mantle of Captain America
as Steve Rogers passed over his shield, but
Bucky himself seemed to agree the honor belonged
to Sam Wilson.
Bucky has an all-around good heart, and fans
have only ever wanted the best for him, given
his tragic past with Hydra.
If he were to die in an upcoming project after
the beautiful closure he had in "The Falcon
and the Winter Soldier," it would be a travesty.
Some people just deserve goodness thrown their
way, and Bucky is one of them.
"Hawkeye" turned out to be one incredible
ride and introduced one of the most fun and
exciting MCU characters of the last few years.
Hailee Steinfeld absolutely nailed the role
of Kate Bishop — a stellar archer who was
inspired by Clint Barton when she saw him
defending New York from the Chitauri in 2012.
Her constant fangirling over Clint was perfectly
ironic, given how there has always been a
debate amongst MCU fans whether Hawkeye might
be the worst Avenger.
Kate is a wonderfully naive character who
is still learning who she is and what her
place is in this superhero world.
This type of young hero is exactly what the
MCU needs moving forward, and taking her out
too soon would be a big hit for the fan base.
There is also much to discover between Kate
and Yelena Belova, and fans are certainly
shipping that potential friendship, whose
roots were laid in "Hawkeye."
These two have the potential to be the MCU's
next besties, so they must be protected
at all costs.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.